yeah I plan on wearing the Santa hat for
this review because Deadpool is wearing
a Santa hat in the poster it doesn't
actually wear it in movies was kind of
out of context of whatever I'm a man
with a plan
maximum effort once upon a Deadpool so
once upon a Deadpool is essentially a
pg-13 cut of Deadpool to s is not
Deadpool 3 there's actually someone in
the screening was like this isn't
Deadpool 3 no it's it's Deadpool 2 again
allowing me to do the easiest review
I've ever done in my life I've already
reviewed Deadpool 2 I'll put a link
below to my Deadpool 2 review and I will
put another link below to my Deadpool 2
spoiler video we try to correct the
timeline timeline but narrative Lee
speaking Deadpool is kidnapped Fred
Savage so he's reading Deadpool 2 to
Fred Savage is bouncing back and forth
between that bedroom and the story of
Deadpool 2 the movie Deadpool 2 if you
seen The Princess Bride you get the
concept if you haven't and when I first
heard about this I thought that could be
really hilarious there are hilarious
parts in it all the stuff with Fred
Savage and Deadpool in that bedroom all
fun but really that's it those are the
reshoots we heard about that's the new
content everything else is a rated pg-13
version of Deadpool 2 not just that but
an edited for television version of
Deadpool 2 when Deadpool 2 comes out on
primetime television it will be
indistinguishable from once upon the
Deadpool save for the Fred Savage stuff
and if that sounds like Deadpool 2 is
the better version of this movie it's
cuz it is why does this movie exist in
the corporate world man seriously
other than Deadpool reading the book to
Fred Savage when it's showing the movie
that you know there's nothing new in
there it's what you've seen before just
not as good it lacks the grit even the
editing you can tell when the audio cuts
maybe it's because I just watched
Deadpool 2 last week but if you don't
hear the audio cut or the voiceover you
see it there are scenes when people are
talking you're like that's not what you
said cuz not all the edits flow you can
tell this wasn't filmed to be pg-13
we've all seen that movies that movie
that's pg-13 but when you're watching it
you're like this is totally film to be
rated R but they've cut things out it
doesn't feel natural and no it's not in
that it's supposed to be that way
because it's meta it's in that edited
for television feeling kind of wet like
let's make more money off this movie but
put as little effort as possible into
doing it I feel like this movie either
exists to show hey pg-13 Deadpool can
work maybe he'll be in the MCU
maybe I don't know or it exists some
Mormons can finally see Deadpool and I'm
talking Mormons who actually obey the
rules and oh you don't watch my videos
because if you're a Mormon who obeys the
rules then [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] this
is now rated R video
what are you watching right now for
shame I will
see you in the teal SEO Kingdom so Paris
if you have little kids and they want to
see Deadpool maybe not this one that's
still a bit gritty for little kids
teenagers sure you can take your
teenagers to go see Deadpool - finally
so you can naively believe that this is
the first time they've seen it like they
didn't sneak into it before they won
really good things back is that song you
know the song when Wade Wilson's in
heaven with Vanessa or mental heaven
whatever it was or the celestial kingdom
as you call it the theatrical version it
played this awesome acoustic version of
take on me but in the extended blu-ray
it's a totally different song just
watching it I wept not because the scene
is sad which it is but I was just I was
just sad we're at the song girl why did
it go and thought it was a licensing
thing but him once upon a Deadpool that
take on me song is back so I was happy
about that still pissed that my version
doesn't have it but in the end this
movie's it's just a cash grab if you've
seen or have Deadpool - on blu-ray you
have the better version of Deadpool -
than that this would have been a great
companion piece for the Deadpool to
blu-ray like if you get the Deadpool to
blu-ray and there's this other disc in
there that's this version of Deadpool -
that'd be kind of fun but a fee at Rakow
released I just don't see why I'm not
gonna give this a rating any more than I
would give a movie that I've reviewed
rated a new rating when I saw it edited
for television on primetime TV those are
my thoughts it's a cash grab the Fred
Savage stuff is funny but as a whole
stick to Deadpool - that you already
have alright so once upon a Deadpool
have you seen it what did you think
about it whatever you thought comment
below let me know and as always if you
like what you've seen here and you want
to see more click right here to see any
more
[Music]